und bei mir im studio jetzt katja glaser
vize sie sind aber heute nicht hier als
promi als sängerin sondern um über ihren
vater zu sprechen erzählen sie uns warum
es missbrauch auch in ihrem leben ein
thema gewesen was ihnen passiert dass
ich missbraucht wurde sodann er meine
freundinnen und er hat jetzt nicht
sexuell vergewaltigt aber hat sich zum
beispiel darf ich überhaupt irgendwelche
wörter sein
er hat sich eine unterhose zum beispiel
und sich dabei zu gucken lassen kleine
mädchen die 89 jahre alt sind direkt
ganz zu tun haben sollten eigentlich und
als das herausgefunden hat dass auch
mich sehr mitgenommen was mich auch bis
heute noch mit nimmt also ich finde
sexueller missbrauch und solche sachen
eben nicht nur die person mitglieder
wieder fahren müssen werden die
persönliches widerfährt sondern auch
noch leitung umkreis das ist halt ein
ausmass ist unglaublich wie haben sie es
damals erfahren oder wann haben sie das
überhaupt erfahren dass dann erfahren
als wir also polizei mussten weil er hat
das so gemacht dass er die mädchen unter
druck gehalten hat zu machen viele
wahrscheinlich also denke ich mir dass
sie einfach sagen wenn du das erzählt
sein gibt es ärger und einer küchen
kleines kind hat angst und einer hat
sich dann zum glück betraut ich glaube
es war auch durch meine mutter weil die
lang gesagt hat er was ist los blablabla
als irgendwann rumgesprochen so war es
war komisch war und dann war ich bei der
polizei hat das haus gefunden wie ist
ihr verhältnis damals ihrem vater
gewesen und vor allem wie ist es jetzt
dadurch geworden dass sie das erfahren
haben
es war relativ okay also er war ein
netter 40 um mich gekümmert er hat nie
den anschein gemacht ist irgendwie ne
macke hat meiner meinung macke und aber
ja er wurde dann immer alkoholabhängiger
gewalttätiger und irgendwann kamen wir
dann auch dazu
also jetzt keinen kontakt mit mich
glaube seit zehn jahren und zu den
freundinnen von damals haben sie noch
kontakt zu den nein gar kein aber die
wollen auch keinen kontakt mit mir haben
bei mir war das ja auch so ist kann auch
auf mich zurück ich habe ja heute gar
nichts zu tun gehabt aber die haben mich
dann auch gehasst die familien so als
hätte ich schuld meine mutter auch
gehasst und dann waren wir so gesehen
komplett gehasst von einläuten und
sondern auch weggezogen direkt schwer
war es für sie das jetzt öffentlich zu
machen und auch jetzt noch darüber zu
sprechen
ich habe das was niemanden kalt zählt
auch nicht meinen freunden also ich
musste das einfach nicht darüber zu
reden was für mich das thema
und ich würde ungern darüber einfach
weil es für mich auch so ein trauma ist
was mich jetzt erst einmal natürlich
trotzdem wichtig dass darüber gesprochen
wird wenn sie jetzt solche fälle sehen
und vor allem wie leicht die strafen
noch oft sind die man was geht ihnen
durch den kopf ich krieg einfach nur
hass und ich frage mich was das soll
ich weiß nicht was es für fälle gibt
aber es gibt auf jeden fall sachen wo
man länger im knast ist als wenn man ein
kind an fest- oder überhaupt ein kind
was antut und das geht gar nicht weil
man endet das leben von dieser person
für immer
es ist krank vielen dank dass sie heute
bei uns waren für diese persönlichen
eindrücken klanke schön